Mark: Okay!
Mark: Alright-
Wade: Up- Down
Mark: *Laughs*
Mark: *laughing gibberish* your guy doing like, is this
Mark: Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier
Mark: And W- *Dying of lack of air*
Mark: *Starts Laughing Like a Madman*
* A GASP FOR PRECIOUS AIR*
Mark: Heeeeeeyyyyyy
Mark: *Laughing, really hard*
Mark: And Welcome to- Uh-
Mark: The Rake!
Mark: Multiplayer Beta
Mark: But! We ( I ) Say beta
Mark: Um...
Mark: This game hasn't been updated, in almost a year... Now
Mark: Uh...The developer like, gave up on it. But... It's here! And there's Multiplayer. And I played this game a while before and it scared me. Not from the monster, but from everything else that happened in the game....
Mark: So let's do it! WADE!
Wade: Do you prefer Shotgun Or Sniper Rifle?
Mark: I'll take... sho'u'tgun
Wade: There you go and there's some sher- shum- shells
*gibberish*
Mark: Okay, so I got the shells... Wait, no, that was rifle ammo
Mark: Wait is that - is that correct?
Wade: There's more right there
Mark: Okay, ah that seems--
Wade: They look like shells...
Mark: Seems good enough for me.
Mark: Okay, so if you guys remember The Rake, The Rake is a game that's made about The Rake!
Mark: Which is a creepy pasta 'bout a creature that's out in the woods...
Mark: Looong spindly arms... it's like um... it's like a Wendigo
Mark: from Until Dawn, remember?
Wade: Yup, I'd say that's accurate
Mark: like that wou- that'd be a fairly apt description, now they're not the same thing
Mark: at least as far as I know
Mark: but they're pretty darn close.
Mark: So, explain the multiplayer, beta, with us.
Mark: Please, Mr. Wade. (Wade: okay)
Wade: So, the multiplayer, from what I've gathered, it's always night-
Wade: The day night cycle doesn't work...
[Mark cuts in] Woah what the fuck? Oh shit, nevermind
Mark: Hang on we're fine!
Mark: Everything's fine!
[Back to Wade] Uh... and uh, that's about it.
Wade: It's always night, there's a couple different guns, there's ammo-
Wade: and there was one wasted ammo
Mark: *sniff*
Mark: Sorry don't mind me. What happens if I shoot you?
Wade: Nothing...?
Wade:Ow.
Mark: *laughter*
Mark: Nothing happens!
Wade: It didnt hurt.
Mark: You're right.
Wade: It-It stunned me.
Mark: Yeah. What happened to Bessy?
Mark: Where's Bessy?
Wade: We don't talk about her.
Mark: Where's Bessy? Where'd Bessy go?
Wade: How do you close this? Oh right here?
Mark: I don't know. I don't think it works anymore.
Mark: There's a lot of th- what was that sound?
Wade: Probably nothing good.
Mark: Probably nothing good.
Wade: I'm gonna go place this other camera before gets to be too late.
Mark: Alright! So yeah it's always night -
Mark: -which means that we're just kinda left out in the
Mark: -lurch in the middle of the woods, and we have no
Mark: -idea what we're doing. Right?
Wade: Pretty much
Wade: Though I do know where some things are    Mark: And there is umm...
Wade: So I can direct
Wade: you to some places.
Mark: I-I-It's been a
while since I played this game, like I
Mark: can't really remember much about the
environment. All I know is that the guy...
Mark: Does he still scream when he gets spooked
by the rake? Like, the guy in the game?
Wade: I think so, yeah.
Mark: Because like that's the
only thing that actually scared me in
Mark: the game besides the pigs that are
wandering around in the woods
Mark: The pi-- It's between the pigs and this guy
are more terrifying than the rake
Wade: Thankfully we have these pathways to
guide us
Mark: Ah, good, great. Ooh...
Wade: So...
*bird mating call*
*Mark answers mating call*
Wade: Now so there's some, there's some ah, useful bear traps up ahead that we
will gather...
Mark: Okay, I'm gunnin' for it. What happens if i step
on them?
Wade: Uh
Wade: nothing good probably...?
Mark: Uuuum, okay.
Wade: I think what- aha, straight up here.
Mark: Okay.
Wade: So--
Mark:Wait--
Mark: Wait for meeee
Wade: Hello ominous music.
Mark: Oh, hello ominous music! It was slightly delayed for me but
Mark: I-I got it
Wade: If you wanna climb up in here and get
those bear traps, I'll go get the ones
Wade: that are over to the left.
Mark: You got it. I'm oooon it... Yeah I remember like- oops-
Mark: I remember like exploring the entirety
of the map and I couldn't really find--
*Rake makes itself known*
Mark: AH! Fucking hell, good god
Wade: *cheeky* Oh, my bad. They weren't up there were they?
Mark: Oh you sack of shit! I actually believed you!
Wade; *laughing*
Mark: That didn't happen before! I actually believed you! I can't believe it
Mark: I trusted you this whole goddamn time--
You get back here you bitch, you're ge-
Mark: Ah fucking crap...
Wade: oh hey look, some bear traps!
Mark: I can't--UGH
Mark: Are you sure? Where? I didn't fucking... alright fine.
Mark: I got the bear traps- the mouse, like,
Mark: it goes outside of the game.
Mark: That's asinine-
Wade: Yeah mine did too
Mark: I can't believe that's still a thing...
Wade: Yeah, that- I-I clicked out a little while
ago and it threw me off
Mark: I- *disbelief* I'm in full screen mode--
Mark: Okay I just can't shoot. If I shoot I
gotta pull a full left turn first
Mark: and then shoot.
Mark: that's what I gotta do. *dinosaur noise*
Wade: I actually don't remember if there's anything in any of
Wade: those or not. That's the only one that has a jump scare as far as I know
Mark: *never trusting Wade again* Uh huh, ok sure yeah. Whatever...
Wade: I'll go in the other one, see? Nothing, nothing happens...
Mark: Let me try, let me try... oh nothing, oh ok, alright, I see.
Mark: I see... Okay, everything's just f--safe and hunky
dory and nothing's gonna eat our faces off!
Mark: What is this, an outhouse?
Wade: Is there a map? I don't remember if there's a map...
Wade: Doesn't look like it.
Mark: M doesn't- there's a map at the beginning of the base,
Mark: in the van I believe.
Wade: Maybe we should go back and figure out
where to go next... I don't remember how to
Wade: get to like the sniper rifle-- we gotta go through
like a cave or something
Mark: Oh yeah, I remember the cave.  But I don't
remember how to get there- I'm totally
Mark: disoriented because it's the middle of
the night obviously.
Wade: Yeah, it's very late... and I keep thinking
I'm hearing zombies because we just
Wade: played 7 days to die not that long ago
so every noise in the night I'm thinking
Wade: we're being attacked.
Mark: Yeah. This is like me and dead by
daylight.
Wade: Wait which one-
Mark: Ha! It's a chainsaw!
Wade: Is this the way we came?
Mark: I don't know! Not by far I don't think
Wade: Aha, yeah here's the gate
Mark: Okay, nevermind. I was completely
wrong, you're right
Mark: *best Wade impression* Oh look at me, I'm Wade. I'm a big smarty-smoo
Wade: Thank you. That's the nicest thing you've
said not sarcastically at all
Mark: Okay, what about behind the van. Is there
anything behind this?
Wade: You.
Mark: *dramatic voice* Me...
Mark: Yeah...
*scary noise*
Mark: *soils self* Oh shit, what the fuck was that?
Mark: What was that?!
Wade: I don't know. I'm not over there anymore.
Mark: There was something scampering
about in the woods.
Mark: Ooh, that sounded bad- It wasn't a--
Wade: It's either a Rake or it was a pig
Mark: It was something...
Mark: Oooh... Me no likey that
Mark: Me no likey that!
Wade: Oh, there's a hou-
Wade; AHHHH!!!
Mark: Whoa, you alright?
Wade; *regret*
Mark: You okay?
Wade: Ohhhh.... He beat me in the buns...
Mark: You okay? You dead?
Wade: I'm good just... pain...
Mark: Which way did you go?
Wade: up the hill, like, to the right.
Mark: The hill to the right...?
Mark: Past this camera that you- oh hey!
Wade: Hey.
Mark: Okay. What'd you find?
Wade: there's a house across
the way and he popped out of a tree and
spanked me
Mark: Oh nice. It's so nice of him that he doesn't
actually kill you...
*camera noises*
Mark: I set a camera!
Wade: Jeez, okay good.
Mark: What? What?
Wade: I can't climb out...
Mark: Oh, you heard the camera sound?
Wade: Yeah, it sounded like it was right in my ear...
Mark: WHOA-- oh god damnit.
Mark: That tree looked really scary.
*camera noise*
Wade: Ooh! Hello tree branch
Mark: Whoa...
Mark: That wasn't me! Did you place a camera?
Wade: No? That was the broken one.
Mark: Oh jeez...
Mark: This might be where we want to go? Might not be...
Wade: Hopefully.
Wade: It's going to take us somewhere.
Mark: Oh, I hear something.
Mark: Ooh what's that? Oooh... Ah, here we are!
Wade: Haha!
Mark: *apprehension* Uuh...
Mark: Hello!
Wade: This is a good place to be- always, always
Mark: Yecch.... Uh oh
Wade: What is that noise?
Mark: I dunno
Mark: It doesn't sound good!
Wade: No it doesn't.
Wade: It doesn't sound good at all!
Mark: Uuuhhh
Wade: Oohhkay...
Wade: Aright I know it's like right around the- we wanna hug the left wall here...
Mark: Okay...
Mark: Whoa...
Wade: Uhhh...
Mark: Where'd you go?
Wade: Up, eh- just- right here
Mark: Oh, there's a boat!
Wade: Yeah there's a foot...
Mark: Oh! I found it!
Mark: There's a sniper rifle right here
Mark: Go get it, get it buddy!
Wade: Yaaaay
Mark: All yers. We did it!
Wade: Did you find the foot?
Mark: Oh, there's a foot!
Wade: Look how big that leg is!
Mark: That's a honking leg.
Mark: Man, comp-- like, with you standing next to it that's a huge leg!
Wade: Yeah...
Mark: Meaty... *fake fear* If The Rake can kill that thing... Oooh noo...
Wade: Yeah... Y'know, I've never actually explored
over here other than to get the sniper rifle.
Wade: Is there anything else over here?
Mark: I don't know... sounds like there's water...
Mark:  Other than that I have no idea.
Wade: Oh my goodness. There was a plant that  just had the wrong shape...
Wade: Looks like a- maybe it's the house I was looking for
Mark: Ehh, could be. Looks like there's a light on in there...
Wade: Yeah...
Mark: Ooh, that's the waterfall! I remember
seeing that 'cause I spotted that in
Mark: the distance too. I was like "What is that? It's amazing!"
Mark: And then it was a waterfall
Wade: Is there anything at the waterfall?
Mark: I don't think so, but there's- there's
also beacons of light? Do you see that?
Mark: Oh it's water.
Mark: No it's not..?
Mark: .... It's little flowers.
Wade: There's a cave under the waterfall.
Mark: Ooh is there?
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: I'll join you in the cave.
Mark:  Hello. *crunching noises* ooh... ah... ah that sounds bad!
*crunching noises*
Wade: I hear it!
Mark: *fearful gibberish*
Wade: I hear that munching noise. I don't see anything...
Mark: Wh- why?
Wade: I don't know...
Mark: Wh-what was-- Oh hello. What is this?
Mark: Is this is the grave that you're gonna bury
me in because you dragged me all the way over here?
Wade:*worst hillbilly impression* I know what you did with Laurie.
Mark: *nervous hillbilly laugh* No, uh...
Mark: *pubescent hillbilly voice* Rick, come on. It's been years
Mark: We let this meme die! *laughs*
Wade: You think we let it but we don't.
Mark: *laughter*
Mark: Yew think yew kin resurrect et, but yew can't.
Wade: Yew think Ah can't but-- Ah would ask you-- tuh lemme try
Mark: *wheezy laugh*
Mark: Carrlll! *laughter*
Wade: Fer Carrrrl!
Mark: Caaarrrrl! *more laughter*
Mark: Man, if nobody remembers that... I don't blame you...
Mark: Man, it--it wasn't worth remembering
Wade: *unintelligible* --be in here
Mark: Yeah... and it's absolute- this is dick.
Wade: Yeah. Well, I don't know what the point of
that was. Why have this entire cave
system but nothing in it?
Mark: I don't know, it's really bizarre...
Mark: *laughs* Well, why have a lot of things
in this game but nothing in it?
Wade: That's true.
Mark: Very good questions...
Wade: I'm gonna kee-- ooh, that looks like thorns...
Wade: I'm gonna keep looking for a house.
Wade: There's got to be that house around here...
Mark: Yeah... Well, what was in the house?
Mark: Jumpscares?
Wade: I think there's more ammo.
Mark: Oh... Well, we don't really need it.
Mark: I mean, have you ever managed to
actually kill the rake?
Wade: Yes.
Mark: Oh, okay...
Wade: By...
Wade: cheating it...
Mark: That's okay. I'm alright with cheating. Trust me.
Wade: In fact, the last time-- if I remember
right-- we had a dance party with it.
Mark: Nice!
Mark: That sounds great!
Wade: It was very lovely.
Mark: Mmmm.
Mark: Is there anything on the map in the van
that shows where a house might be?
Wade: Maybe.
Wade: *scaredy laughter* If we can find our way back.
Mark: I don't think we can. I think we're
screwed.
Mark: Why haven't I seen any piggies? :c
Mark: I used to see lots and lots of piggies
when I was playing before...
Wade: They are a bit rarer now... oh there's something--
Wade: Wait, this is the same waterfall?
Mark: No way.
Mark: No, this is different.
Mark:  Yeah, this has got a bigger leading up to it.
Wade: Okay.
Mark: Well, that's weird.
Wade: Anything around?
Wade: Anything in this one?
Mark: There's another thing behind it.
Mark: It looks like shotgun ammo or sniper ammo?
Mark: Shotgun?
Wade: It looks like shotgun.
Mark: I can't click on it.
Mark: It's not clickable.
Wade: Well that's helpful.
Wade: There's been a shortage, I feel, like of
quality horror games and there's not been a
Wade: whole lot of creepy pasta related games
in awhile that I've found so...
Mark: There hasn't been a lot of new creepypasta in forever.
Wade: Oh that's true... there's not-- there's not been much love given to The Rake though, this is the
Wade: only game i really know of about it.
Mark: Yeah, the other Rake games were just
terrible...
Wade: Yeah it's a hard monster to incorporate. At least this was an open-world attempt at it I guess?
Mark: Yeah... I mean-- but this game being not
developed isn't quite like you know
Mark: P.T. being cancelled like...
Wade: Yeah it's not that big of a loss but...
Wade: It--It's still...
Wade: I heard-- I've not played it, I heard the new
Resident Evil looks pretty promising though.
Mark: Oh yeah, it looks really good. Like-- I-I
mean obviously when I played the demo
Mark: they're trying to be P.T., that's what they
were going for.
Mark: They were going for that hard-to-figure-out-what-the-hell-is-going-on style and
Mark: you know they're obviously trying to
mimic that but you know i-it still had promise.
Wade: The only bad thing I heard about it was
apparently they had some time lock stuff
Wade: that angered people.
Mark: Time lock?
Wade: Yeah. Apparently there's like a...
Wade: finger? There were some random objects you
couldn't use but then they time-locked some stuff
Wade: just so that you have to wait till they
unlocked it to use it.
Mark: Oh, that's stupid.
Mark: I didn't even know about it unlocking later...
Mark: I found another, uh, perch.
Mark: Oohh, I'm almost back to camp... okay good.
Wade: I keep finding waterfalls. I'm just gonna keep running in a straight line to see where I end up.
Mark: Man, why do you keep finding waterfalls?
Wade: 'Cause I'm probably wandering
around stupid...
Mark: Probably.
Mark: *sigh*
*thudding noise*
Mark: Whoa
Wade: WHOA!!!!1!
Wade: OH GOD!!
Mark: *all the nope*
Mark: What was that?
Wade: It jumped out of a bush...
Mark: Oh...
Mark: Okay...
Mark: You alright?
Wade: *heart stopped* Yeah...
Mark: Heh, man you're getting all the scares
and not me.
Wade: I-- Yeah, I lead you to one scare and now I'm paying the price for it.
Mark: *laughter at Wade's expense*
Mark: It's karma baby, it's karma...
Wade: It was at the house we got the traps-- the other side of that house, he popped out...
Mark: Oh, ok... sure...
Wade: Oh jeez Louis... I deserved that but god...
Mark: *laughing* I'm gonna  check the cameras that I placed, let me see...
Mark: *camera sounds* camera one, camera two...
Mark: Huh... I see nothing!
Mark: *beautiful singing* I see...
Mark: fieeelds of black...
Mark: Oh god-- I see you! *laughs* Holy shit. I saw you creeping up on one of the cameras.
Mark: *second thoughts* Th-th-that was you right?
Wade: Yeah th- that was-- *laughs* no, that was another random hunter.
Mark: W-Wade, is that you?
Mark: Ohgod...
Mark: The scariest creature is man!
Mark: You better have a good reason for
me being out in these woods!
Mark: I haven't seen no Rake 'round here...
Mark: Oh, holy shit--
Mark: Where the fuck did you come from?
Wade: Hi!
*door closes*
Mark: Woah, I didn't know you could close that...
Mark: Well, where's the goddamn Rake?
Wade: I don't know--
Wade: Oh-- he broke the camera up on the--
Wade: He always--
Wade: Okay, he loves to break this camera up on
this hill
Mark: Oh alright, well I'm gonna put a camera up
there and then I'm gonna wait
Mark: we're gonna wait for him...
Mark: and when he
attacks you because he doesn't like you
Mark: we're gonna get it--Aw, I was gonna do that.
Mark: Alright.
Mark: Where he at?
Wade: Trap down? I'm going to put a bear trap down.
Wade: Nope.
Mark: Ah, fuck it--
Mark: AAHH! WHAT THE FUCK!
Mark:  HI!
Mark: OW! Mah face!
Mark: Ow...
Wade: I gotta get some footage of this...
Mark: what did you watch that?
Wade: No, I was too late.
Mark: Oh man...
Mark: Well, I'll stay out here then...
Mark: So you can get the good footage!
Wade: And make sure I close the door...
Mark: AH! I hit a bear trap...
Mark:  I'm an idiot...
Mark: I'm- it's dead by daylight all over again.
Wade: This is just like that! Yeah, JUST like that--
Wade: I- we placed those!
Mark: Oh man... or maybe it didn't? I'm dying, I
need to get back and eat- get some health.
Mark: Well... Okay, first aid
*moist squish*
Mark: *mouth fart* Oh, why was that so WET?
Mark: Why was that so wet? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Wade: I don't know...
Wade: Oh. The door closing is kind of stirring when- -
Mark: I know, yeah.
Mark: When you're not ready for it.
Wade: Yeah...
Mark: You stay safe in the van.
Mark: I'll be back by morning.
Wade: I'm watching you.
Mark: Are you?
Mark: You'll let it know if it comes up behind me right?
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: Okay...
Mark: *Mic explodes* AH FUCK! OKAY, AHHH! AAH! AAHH!
Mark: Were you looking?!
Wade: Yeah I saw that, it was great footage!
Mark: Ok good! *laughs* I hope it was worth it!
*Rake coming back for round 2*
Mark: Oh, oh god... he hits- oh, where--
Mark: He's running right towards the van!
Wade: Alright, I'll pull out my rifle...
Mark: AH! God dammit he got me again! *laughs*
Mark: That sack of shit!
Mark: Okay... Well he's hanging around now..
Mark: Oh god- Not again!
Mark: God dammit I'm stuck in a loop!
Wade: I don't- I don't see him!
Mark: Help!
Wade: Oh that's him! *ignores Mark*
Mark: Oh geez, he's in camp...
Mark:  Whoa, that's weird...
Mark: Okay, I'm--
Mark:  Ouhh--
Mark: Okay, are we safe up here?
Wade: I think so...
Wade: AH!
Mark: *more laughter at Wade's expense*
Mark: Just seeing you get hit... that's really funny...
Wade: *more regret*
Mark: Okay.
Wade: That's one of the ways to break the game, kind of, is to stand up there
Wade: 'cause if you're up there, he just dances around.
Mark: Okay. I'm gonna place bear traps
around the camp.
Wade: That's a good idea.
(that's not a good idea)
Mark: I got a lot of 'em.
Mark: Seems good...
Wade: Well if he comes after us he's gonna regret it.
Wade: And if we have to have run anywhere we're gonna regret it
*Mark laughs*
Mark: We got the back of the van, that'll probably
be good enough for our survival.
Wade: Yeah. I'm trying, it's not working...
Mark: ♫Come out, come out, wherever you are!♫
Wade: ♫'Cause we're ready for huntin'♫
Mark: ♫We're rednecks with a lot of guns!♫
Wade: ♫Get my Moonshine♫
Wade: YeAh
*Mark laughs*
Mark: Yeeah.
Mark: You sound so unsure about your moonshine, you think that as a hillbilly you would've known-
Mark: *revelation* You're not a real hillbilly are ya?
Wade: *so sophisticated* No I am not, you have caught me in my lie.
Mark: *hillbilly* W-W-What are you,
some sort of fancy pants?
Wade: *sophisticate* Yes that is- I'm from Fancy Pants, Rhode island.
Mark: *hillbilly* Wow, that-- I didn't know that was
real town but considering I'm
Mark: just a dumb hillbilly I believe you.
Mark: Sorry, I fired off! *laughter*
Mark: I hit control-- I didn't know control was shot
Wade: *hillbilly* Don't mind me wettin' myself here!
*Mark laughs*
Wade: I'm devolving into a hillbilly, I think
I'll *hillbilly speak* right there!
Mark: *hillbilly* That's what happens when you nearly get shot.
Wade: *hillbilly* It is, you devolve into hillbilly.
Wade: 'Cause I think it's really good for me to be up here with a sniper rifle
Wade: before he gets nice and close.
Mark: Yeah... okay I'm watching.
Mark:  Man this camera's shaky
Mark: I'm gonna watch you get eaten.
Mark: *hungry* I'm gonna watch you.
Mark: I'm gonna watch when it happens.
Mark: ...'cause it's so janky.
Wade: See... Ah, oh I stepped on a- ah oh!
*Mark laughs*
Mark: You just went completely horizontal when you went on the ground!
Mark: Uhhh... oh you died!
Wade: I lost my sniper rifle ;__;
Mark: Oh come on man!
Mark: We probably needed that maybe...
Mark: Probably everybody at home is getting sick...
Wade: I went face first-
Mark: Ah! I hit a god damn fucking bear trap!
(told you it wasn't a good idea)
Mark: Why are there so many bear traps around the camp?
Wade: I'm face first into this one.
Mark: Where are you?
Wade: Up on the hill.
Mark: Oh...
Wade: The hill that has all the bear traps to get up too.
Mark: Oh god I hit it again!
*Wade laughs*
Mark: Fuck- why is there an option to be The
Rake?
Wade: I wish we cou- oh you died too?!
Mark: Uh, yeah...
Mark: Oh my god, my corpse is face first
and--
Mark: AH! I hit another one!
Mark: God dammit...
Wade: Stop running into them!
Mark: I'M NOT!
Mark: I'm so fa- oh there's- oh, did you hit one?
*silence*
Wade: No...? ._.
Mark: Oh, did IT hit one?
Wade: It must've.
Mark: Well, we don't have a shotgun or a sniper rifle so we ju-
Wade: We need to find the house that has the other gun!
Mark: We have to beat it to death with our fists.
Mark: Oh, here's another corpse!
Mark: Well...
Wade: Oh hey, I moved! I'm no longer in the bear trap. The Rake must've... come by...
Mark: Oh my god.
Mark: It's here.
Mark: *bear trap fail* krrrrrshAAAAAGHH
Wade: Woah, hello! You just rained in from the sky.
Mark: Oh, there's so many bear traps...
Wade: WOW!
Mark: How many corpses can we leave?
Wade: Watch whenever we die. Watch the spawn, like-- okay.
Wade: So you stare at this point
right here
Mark: Alright, ready.
Wade: Wee!
*Mark laughing*
Mark: You like...  zoom in...
Mark: You zoom in from who knows where...
Mark:  Oh, there's so many corpses.
Mark: Alright, so I guess we're done here. We
kind of broke the game.
Mark: We got a giant pile of corpses here, um,
Mark: of assorted people...
Mark: They actually-- it's weird, they don't actually
Mark: look like us, these-these dead bodies.
Mark:They're-- we're wearing like yellow ban-
Mark: AH! Fucking, bear trap...
Mark: Anyway, we're all done here. Hope you enjoyed this--
Mark: Um, we can't figure out other ways to play
this game,
Mark: because The Rake doesn't want to play nicely.
Mark: So, thank you everybody so
much for watching,
Mark: thank you Wade for joining me on this one.
Wade: My pleasure.
Mark: Check out Wade's channel in the description below.
Mark: And as always,
Mark: we will see you in the next video.
Buh-Bye!
*Outro plays*